因为啊，你想让别人改变观念，让别人重视这个孩子，就这事儿的话，我感觉啊，就跟烧香拜佛是一个意思。这个主动权是在别人手里的观念，在别人脑子里的态度，在别人掌握的钱，是别人挣的人，人家想怎么花钱，人家想怎么做这个事情的话，真的没法去左右我的家庭条件就是农村的不太好。然后，我上学的时候就认识了一个就老公嘛，他家条件就比我们家好。从结婚的时候，我就是先怀孕后结婚的。他们家那个时候就是有一点欺负人了，反正也不太想跟我在一起，三金什么的都没有给我买。后面，我们生了两个孩子，第一个是女儿，第二个是儿子。生女儿的时候，大家都相安无事的。生完儿子以后，我的儿子他出现了早产，因为我怀孕的时候，我既要怀着孩子，还要带一个孩子。那个时候，大家都挺好的，就是表面都很客气。后面生第二胎，也是因为他奶奶就跟我说，我们家条件可以是的，你生了我跟你讲，我那时候比较小嘛，我就是相信我们一家人。然后我就生了。生了之后，孩子出现了早产，因为他们期间就不带孩子嘛，我一个人带就很累。后面也吵过我，我就说这个孩子我带不了，我太累了，他们家就推卸责任，就不肯带，我也不想连累我妈，我就一个人扛，我就带着。后面我就早产了，然后小孩子就出现了，后续的一系列的。
康复费用不是很贵嘛，我那个时候我就去找他们要，然后他们呢也不是说不给也给，但是是不支持我持续的康复条件是有的哈，就是有这个能力的。他们家一年大概100个这样，我说我就要嘛，每次回去我就哭呀，就哭呀，要呀，然后他们就不给，就说这个是你们两个人的事情，跟我们没关系，我们出了这么多，已经仁至义尽了。我们当长辈的没有义务去给你出这个。但是我说都是独生子嘛。嗯，他爸这期间一直都是在那个网上有那种就是一直说啊说啊说啊的那种。他爸一直都是这个情况。然后我让他爸去做中年人去要这个这个小孩康复的费用，他就说他要不来，因为他也不争气嘛。他爸妈也不拿他当回事，那我更不用说了。我就想让我孩子好，我就去要。我每次就去要孩子，现在已经16岁了，然后每次都是我死乞白赖的要半年，然后再回家休息半年，要半年休息半年，这期间也花了大概有30万左右吧。他爸呢，这方面他带进去了得有个四十万五十这样，中间呢，他就是威胁我就说，你如果不帮我还这个债务的话，我爸就会知道我有这个情况了，他就不可能再给你钱给孩子看病。那我心想，那肯定还是看病更重要，我就说。
我妈给我的那个她存在我这里的私房钱，然后我就偷偷给他还了一点叽叽答喳的我给他大概还了10个这样左右，后面呢，孩子他们也就不想康复了。后来没办法，不康复吧，我就把孩子带回去我自己做，他又在网上那个了，我就一直都带两个孩子的哈，然后他就在网上那个，后来，我就没办法了。他爸就说过，我说，如果你再发现他有这种情况，你隐瞒我了话，我就扇你脸。因为每次擦屁股都要找他们嘛。所以后来我就立马打电话给他爸爸，我说，你快过来，我说，他又有那种情况了，太气我啊，我直接告他爸了，就是吵呗，就闹呗，他就对我冷暴力啊，然后什么什么的，就觉得这些行为。然后，后来，我们吵着吵着就吵凶狠了。他就把我手在门上给我夹流血了。我就打电话给他的爸爸了。我说，你们过来，我说我受伤了。他来了之后，他就骂我一顿。他把我骂一顿了，说我在看手机，说我无所谓的样子。我说，我看手机是因为我在发信息啊。他们就骂我说，我这点小事情，还把他们叫来说，他们第二天早上还得买菜呀干嘛的，因为他们家时做开店的嘛，做餐饮的就骂我，他就说这种小事，然后我就很委屈，我就录音，我就把他录下来了。录下来他就觉得他的权利受到了侵害，然后他就骂我呀，说他妈的打我妈的，跟我说他肯定是气话，我知道的，然后就摔我手机，但是没打我。
后面我也就是结了这么多年，我就很委屈。我后来我就头不肯地了，我就不愿意委屈自己。之前一闹，我就走走了没几天，哄哄我就回来了。后来真知道我就觉得我什么都不要了，我就要走。然后我就走了。走了之后，我也申请了，申请了两孩子，我也没问，我就走掉了。走掉了之后，他们也没来找我，顶多就是发个信息说你回来，你回不回来？不回来就在外面吧，就这样，然后我也不低头，最后就装了领了领了之后呢，我就出去上班了。这俩孩子现在是谁在带？因为我妈她有那个肝硬化，经常住院，带不了我家条件也不好，我还有一个妹，还有个弟，就是孩子。后来呢，他爸不是有这个债务嘛，在我这儿，对不对我因为有个朋友是当律师的，我那时候咨询了他，他就让我留个心眼。所以当时我跟他签的时候，他认为我永远不会离开他们的，所以我怎么写他就怎么签了。因为他爸他认为他拿捏住我了，我只是在闹脾气，所以我当时把那个房子写到我的名下了。你拿给我儿子给他，然后，他欠我的这个债务我也写进去了之后呢，他就是没有能力还我这个债务嘛。我当时是愿意在家带孩子的，他只愿意给我5000。因为谈好像是8000。他后来就说我不值，因为他们家觉得好像我不会。
付了所以说，他们就觉得多给我钱了，就亏我当时是想的是给我的话，我带两个孩子，我没有积蓄，我存不下来。然后我就去上班了。我说，那就孩子给你们带吧，你要生活费从这个欠我的债务里面扣嘛。然后在县城里面，我跟他妈妈谈了，我说那就你扣我2000，然后我就去上班了。我不跟你讲了，儿子有那个问题嘛，今年暑假的时候，我是一放假我就把孩子接到我那边去了。干的这个职业，我是可以把孩子放在家里几个小时，然后我出去上几个小时就可以了。因为我是卖衣服的，然后他奶奶呢，我就跟他提了一嘴，我就为了孩子，我还子说了一句，我就说那孩子越来越差了，你看得见，我就给他一顿的就是那种就是道理嘛大道理嘛，讲给他听，他就一下同意了，愿意让孩子去看了。然后我赶忙就把工作辞了，我就带着孩子那看看两个月看两个月就不看了。然后他就回家了。她一个月带两个孩子来这，她就走了，她就回家了。她说她不舒服难受，让他体检，你什么问题啊，姐妹啊，咱们是要解决问题的啊，你具体想问我啥问题？我的意愿是什么？就是我在想我怎么才能改变这些情况。1我是想改变他们家人的想法，让他们能持续的给这个孩子康复，因为有这个能力，不是说没有。第二，就是这个房子，他就是一直。
带了一年不走嘛，我后面我就给他转电了。因为我回去之后看孩子，我没地方住，同时他谈了女朋友，我也不想让他们住在这个房子里，因为本身这个已经是我名下了，然他给我带孩子，我已经退步了。房子给你住，改变别人这事儿。姐妹啊，你想让别人改变观念，让别人重视这个孩子，就这事儿的话，我感觉啊，就跟烧香拜佛是一个意思，这个主动权是在别人手里的观念，在别人脑子里的态度，在别人掌握的钱是别人挣的人家想怎么花钱，人家想怎么做这个事情的话。真的没法去左右。因为我很迷茫，因为我感觉我既要又要，因为我想让他们给孩子看。还有一个就是这个房子，我断店以后，他把我里面所有的家电全部都搬走了，我在想这个房子我是卖还是租。然后还有一个就是我女儿这个问题，因为我带不了嘛，我没法给她提供好的环境和好的教育。我在外地没有房，我什么都没有租房子住，我带过去，我没法给他学校上，而且我在江苏那边，然后我不知道怎么安置这一切，我就是很迷茫，我感觉房子如果说你下定决心的话，房子可以卖掉。因为房子确实是白纸黑字给了你嘛。那你可以卖掉，卖掉房子你就拿点钱。如果可以的话，你去做一个测试，看是不是有抑郁的倾向，或者有这种心理上的。
这样一些问题，如果有的话，咱们还是先顾着自己，先把自己治好了。我有这方面倾向吗？我觉得我没有去看一看保险一点对自己负责任，我都去看过，我没有别的意思啊，因为我本人，我都去看过，我去看过精神科，我去做过测试，我去看看我有没有抑郁倾向，我去看看我有没有焦虑倾向。我感觉这事儿就跟看感冒是一个意思，因为我不是专业的人，我不能判断诊断我自己有没有抑郁，所以我就专门去看。我感觉这事儿没啥好丢人的啊，去看一下很正常啊。我一想到他们如果不给这个小孩看了，其实他很好，你知道吗，他是轻微的那种脑瘫，就是走路有一点点不好，但是他如果不康复就会走的很难看，我就老想着让他们来支持给他看。还有一个想法是这个阿子已经判给他了嘛，就是我在想我要不要把这个房子卖了。卖了以后呢，卖给他还再给他看，卖了的话，那个只能卖30个左右，我只能看一年呀，然后我就一无所有。我还有一个问题，就是我为什么前怕狼后怕虎的这样也不敢做，那样也不敢做？因为没有人给我带小孩。我要想自己挣钱，我得让他帮我带小孩。我也不能说狠心一下就把小孩放到老家去，不闻不问。我妈是个很不适合带小孩的人，她脾气非常的暴躁，然后就是有点文化。
他比较低嘛，他奶奶最起码就是见过大世面的，带孩子还挺好，他对孩子是真心的，这是真的就是小孩，他现在也愿意带。还有一个问题就是他让我把这个房子签个协议，他说给你住可以，你现该给我这个协议，这房子你以后必须给这个小孩，让我另份这个协议。还有一个就是让我在一个月给他那个3000块钱，他说，这个对账也可以，但是呢，我一个月得给3000，我感觉你得逃离这段关系，逃离这个环境，你才能够变好，才能够心里更阳光一点，心情好一点。你现在就是套在这段关系里面，感觉快把自己给套死了。你要想卖你就卖掉房子，拿着钱，你离得远一点，卖小孩呢，因为毕竟那小孩其名义上是给我的，我怎么办，但是现在不是奶奶在帮忙带嘛？你卖了房子，你有了钱了，你先去看看心里有没有什么抑郁。你先治疗自己，等你什么时候哎呀，自己身体也健康了，心理也健康了，你找份工作了，你有收入了，你收入很稳定了，你再回来接小孩儿好吧。他现在就意思必须得我给我3，你不给我3的话，那我就不带你就带走，就是这个意思，那我没法带走你现在这个情况，反正两个孩子在婆婆那儿，婆婆不会把这两个小孩饿死冻死，对吧？你先去这。
养好自己，以我的判断的话，我感觉你是有点抑郁倾向了。你先把自己治疗好再说好吧。现在我带着孩子在康复呢，我其实想跟他沟通呢，就是说跟我提这些，我都能答应你。但是我要提的要求就是你给这个小男孩，你给他再看一眼，那你可以提这个要求啊，你看他答不答应啊。你提要求是你的事儿，人家答不答应是人家的决策的事儿啊，他们所有人都跟我讲说他不会同意的，然后他也没也跟我讲，就算娶了，即使会同意，也是让你耗在这里，他不会来的，我就还得耗在这儿。我俩就只能聊到这儿了啊。确实，你的这个扣想要解的话，就是取舍，没办法，因为一直就是我就解不开在这里，我不知道我怎么做才能更好，你先把自己做好，先找到让你能够安静下来。龙飞姐，我对你没有恶意啊，以我的判断，以我的经验来判断的话，你大概率下现在是抑郁了。你先去把自己的这个状况，精神状况，这个心理状况，你先去治疗一下，等你这个自己治疗好了之后，你才有可能对孩子好。其实某种程度上来说，孩子现在跟着你也未必是好事儿，因为你现在每天都是这种不好的情绪嘛，你跟孩子在一起的话，未必是好事儿。那我房子，我是卖了还是租的呢？卖掉吧，卖掉你才有。
可能跟这一家人有一些剪得断的关系，还有一个就是我卖我也害怕，因为我怕我卖了会激怒他们，他们会采取那种就是极端的方式，然后我还是会很痛苦，他会弄那个女孩小丫头，然后来要挟我怎么办？那就先暂时别卖，你自己先出去找份工作好吧。咱俩今天只能聊到这儿了啊，我现在也没有那么多的妄念，这个妄念是什么呢？好像我能解决一切的问题，不是的，这些事情有些东西就是我的能力也是解决不了的，那只能是走一步看一步。这是实话。我希望所有来连麦我的姐妹们心里都要有这样一个预期，就是龙飞姐能解决这一世间一切的苦难吗？这一切的问题吗？这一切的悲剧吗，我解决不了，我只能是说帮助大家从你自身的利益出发的话，你现在最需要做的是把孩子还给婆婆，甭管她是不是带孩子去康复，你把孩子给婆婆，然后你先去治愈你自己。大概率下，以我的判断的话，这女孩儿大概率下是有一些抑郁了，焦虑了。如果说你自己的抑郁和焦虑这个问题不解决掉，不控制，那以后就算环境好了，就算孩子好了，你依然是过不好的。就这个意思，记得点赞关注哦。